again
i'm going to ask you one question i'm
curious enough if you have any other
kind of version of story to this john f
kennedy
assassination i've heard hey now i've
interviewed 20 people on the topic of
john f k
you know jfk assassination what do you
know the involvement of ruby the mob
the cia lbj what do you know so so jimmy
blue eyes tells me the story okay
i used to meet with him once a month
downstairs in the hilton hotel
so i said to him one time i said jimmy
this kid uh harvey oscar
he says we have better [ __ ] shooters
than
lee harvey oswald it's all [ __ ] we
had nothing to do with them
i said but tell me the story
he says okay joe kennedy
all right joking the nicest thing you
could have said about joe kennedy
is that he hated italians more than he
had to jews couldn't stand italians
could he couldn't stand jews so
um he wanted jack kennedy to become
president
he reaches out to peter lawford his uh
son-in-law you were friendly with that
little
skinny guinea frank sinatra
we need a favor what's the favor you go
to him
you're part of the rat pack tell them we
need
cook county chicago we need west
virginia
unions in order to get
uh kennedy elected
um chicago
um dewey no no no dewey was new york
the prosecutor no the irish daily
daily richard daley uh irish catholic
uh democrat uh ceremony
all right they get together we're gonna
get this guy elected
all right now um
it gets elected all right
here's the here's the mentality you came
to me for a favor
your man got elected it was
me that got him elected
our guy got him elected oh
oh we got a claim on you
you owe us big time
joe kennedy says what's happening
he said well these italians are by the
way you [ __ ] with these italians
you got a girlfriend by the name of
judith extra campbell
she's between you and sam moody you're
sharing a girlfriend
you're sending messages to him he's
sending messages to you
squid that [ __ ] where's your brother
robert come here
come here bobby you're going to be
the united states attorney general all
right because you're mean and vicious
like the old man
your brother jack all he wants to do is
screw everybody
all right so you're going to get rid of
these italians
because they are a pain in the ass
they're a pain of my
irish ass okay
he opens up the crime uh uh
passes a bill called the omnibus which
is the
preface to the eventual local the uh
um uh rico
all right he has a department within the
state
within the united states department of
justice auntie
and anti-mafia it all right it starts
with robert kennedy
now in the mind of the italians they
said wait a minute
i spent the quiet what are you doing
here we got you elected now you're going
to go after us you son of a [ __ ]
kennedy bastards i told you you never
could trust an irishman
that irish son of a [ __ ] and so forth
and so forth now
i used to go to dallas texas at the
black pinball machines
from an old friend of my dad by the name
of abe sussman oh
and he was abe was the connection jew in
in dallas
so dallas always answered to chicago
chicago everybody that grew in dallas
and
well everything west of uh up until
vegas vegas was over jackson chicago
japan makes sense yeah
so if some jew from chicago got himself
jammed up in dallas
they used to call abe and say hey we got
one of your jews here got it get them on
an airplane get them that lady yeah all
right
that was the system in dallas texas
and that explains how jack
rubinstein jack ruby was in the
dallas police department because he used
to buy coffee hang around
he was low level but he was a low-level
jewish gangster from chicago all right
now
it raises the whole question
what the hell was jack ruby doing in the
dallas police department
and killing lee harvey oswald
so where it concerns
legends and myths all right we'll sit
here from now
until the cows come home because the
same stories over and over who killed
loggies willman
who killed this one who killed that one
and so forth who killed marilyn monroe
if you weren't there if you weren't
involved in a hit you don't know
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye-bye